normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government here's
a story from the post millennial Elon
Musk considers bringing Alex Jones back
to X will run a poll to decide so here's
what happens we uh we have Tucker
Carlson drop his interview with Alex
Jones the quartering tweets think about
how much letting Alex Jones back on X
would make the machine rage Elon Musk
it's time Elon respond
will consider in general since this
platform aspires to be the global Town
Square permanent bans should be
extremely rare also if he does say
something false on this platform then
Community notes will correct him whereas
that would not be the case elsewhere and
then he says let's hold a poll so this
could be it I think uh I I think with
this boycott the attack against Elon
Musk and X which is clearly nonsensical
uh Elon earlier was tweeting at Disney
because Instagram and met uh Instagram
and Facebook meta companies were sued by
the New Mexico AG for advancing allowing
and facilitating child abuse and all
that entails trafficking Etc and
materials and so Elon Musk is saying why
why are they still advertising on the on
this platform how come all these
advertisers are on Facebook with no
problem about something we've all known
about now for how it's been like a year
since the initial reports came out that
they were doing this and no action's
been taken and they're boycotting X I
think actions like that result in Elon
being like all right screw it Alex Jones
is back I I think that Alex Jones coming
back is probably baked into the kick now
I I don't know that I don't know that I
agree that the the treatment of musk
currently by the government and by the
other media establishment um is is the
defining factor I think that the
conversation that that um Tucker Carlson
had with uh with with Jones I listened
to about half of it on the way on the
way here today um and I think that
there's a lot of compelling uh there's a
lot of compelling stuff in the
conversation that would that would I
think would make musk uh kind of sit up
and be like oh I I misunderstood because
if I understand correctly musk's
position was Alex Jones did do this and
that's why he was booted off and
apparently um that is not the case so I
I don't I don't know I think Elon musk's
position was publicly whoa Alex Jones
said a bunch of bad things so you know
there's there's a line but in reality it
was guys there's only so much I can do
right we he was trying to avoid having
every Advertiser just jump off the
platform but if that's happening already
seems like elon's like all right screw
it whatever well I think I mean he
probably kind of I mean maybe there is a
little more to your initial comment than
I than I initially said because he's
probably he probably is thinking well
you know they're banning they're they're
affecting my advertising base anyways
right like i' I've done the things that
that you're supposed to do to get along
with them but because I own X and don't
want to you know just allow the FBI to
have an office in my building um because
of that then they're still going to go
and try and attack me and and try and
ruin the business I think that uh I
think that he that that probably does
have an a significant impact on his his
take fully agree that's exactly what I
think is happening they and I would even
consider that the advertisers aren't
even boycotting X they're boycotting
Elon they're it's a personal it seems
personal I think it's governmental
oh I think yeah like I said I like
that's why I said uh mentioned an an FBI
desk in Twitter because that's
essentially what they had before I
forget what his name was the guy that
was the FBI lawyer that worked at
Twitter he was the Twitter's top lawyer
but in the same way that you don't leave
the Intel establishment like if you get
out of you know you stop working at CIA
and you go working go to a uh a tech
company you're still working for CIA at
a tech company because you still have
the connections you're still making you
still have the you know you still can
talk to the people that you used to work
with and you know for a fact the
higher-ups the bureau Chiefs and stuff
or the higher-ups at CIA are calling you
up and saying hey can you get me this or
can you do this if they want something
from the tech companies You could argue
that tech companies big tech companies
are we can be weaponized I mean just
like Boeing can be weaponized they're
100% already part of the military
industrial complex EXA but they also
make commuter Jets like they'll make
commercial airliners but then they were
also machines were weaponized for war
and social media I think can also be
very very easily so is there are they
right do you what do you think well I I
want to ask you did have you worked on
any of the weaponization stuff while
they're they're tracking what was going
on with collusion no I haven't I'm on
homeland security small business and
Veterans Affairs I think it's great I'd
love to see Alex back on uh back on
X yeah oh he's back on SEC you have to
have a a clearance for that and stuff
clearance for what for Homeland Security
oh yeah every every member of Congress
get okay I didn't know that yeah what is
it no uh uh what level of clearance are
we are we allowed to know um I mean I
don't think there's too much that you're
not allowed to see as a member of
Congress no I mean like does the public
know the degree of clearance that
members of Congress get is it publicly
known like if you're in Congress you get
top secret or something yeah yeah I I
mean yeah you you you get top secret oh
okay well then yeah I want to know
what's going on with uh uh I I don't
think it's a coincidence that meta's
meta's apps are now wide wi widad
reporting about the facilitation of
child abuse not a single Advertiser
cares the same thing happened with with
the whole January 6 thing everybody all
of the evidence shows that the people
that did talk about you know going to
the protest and possibly rioting or
whatever they were all making the coners
they were all having conversations on
Facebook and yet the government blamed
parler and went after parer's
infrastructure and basically you know
torpedoed parlor
saying that people were organizing for
the protests and stuff on parlor when in
reality they were doing it on Facebook
then it makes me think that there is
massive government infrastructure in
Facebook and they're happy to keep it
open absolutely for business because
it's like a Honeypot absolutely the the
tech companies whether we realized it or
not the the big social media companies
that we decided you know as a society we
are just going to give all of our
information
to they are the the monitoring apparatus
for the federal government because the
federal government just needs a subpoena
like we we we they don't have to like it
doesn't have to be this big brother
nefarious where they're putting speakers
and stuff or putting microphones in your
car and stuff because they're already
there in fact we we bought all the
speakers and and stuff to put into our
own you know our own homes so they don't
have to do anything except go to a court
and say uh you know we need a we need
you know we need to subpoena these
records we need to subpoena the
communications for this person for these
dates all they have to do is know where
to look the government will go to the
the court the court is there are I would
be willing to bet anything there is not
a court in America that will turn the
federal government down if they say we
need to get we need to subpoena this
information from Google I wonder if
there was a if there was an option for
us to scramble all data on all social
networks so that no one has access to it
if that would actually be good for the
American military industrial complex
defense organiz like if they'd be like
yeah it's better that no no one has it
cuz right now yeah the FBI might have
access to it but sort of this Chinese
CCP they can they can hack it and take
it too and I I wonder if what if it what
they would do if they could do that
because I'm thinking about Quantum
encryption and and post encryption and
stuff like that I want to say that there
was already some kind of legislation
about encryption that the government
doesn't want the population or the
private sector to have encryption
technology they want to they want to
consider it a weapon and say that the
that you know uh companies can't have
encryption that was one of the I heard I
don't have any detail about it I this is
just something that I heard in passing
and I haven't done any kind of studying
up on it but it doesn't surprise me
because the government hates the idea of
not being able to access information
there's like I just did a conversation
with Kevin Kane who does Quantum
encryption or postquantum encryption I
think it's what it's called and they're
they're trying to figure out get ahead
of the game because once they figure out
how to crack encryption with quantum
computers then they need to put some
kind of new encryption in place and it's
like is it even ethical to talk about
this out loud because even if we're just
spitballing ideas like listening you
know I mean they like the CC whoever the
the boogeyman is at the day I'm
confident the government has people
working for them that are way smarter
than me that have thought of things that
I'm not going to think of yeah a lot of
SE I'm I'm not worried about if I like
I'm not worried about giving the
government ideas a lot of the the
federal government is getting ahead of
the curve but it's kind of that thing
like until you know how it can be broken
you don't know what to make to fix to to
prevent it from being broken so you got
to break it before you can improve it
and then that could be like bank records
get released everybody's phone calls
texts uh all that signal all your
encryption stuff is like yo a quantum
computer can can take Vector attacks
like rather than trying to do like ABCD
ABC ABC you don't even need to have
quantum computer because like I said you
just got the courts the courts just say
give it to them and then what if you
don't give it to them no no what I'm
saying is that is like Google they'll
the court will go to Google and say
Google give it to them give it the
information if if if there's back door
access through these big companies I
think that I don't think that there
needs to be back door access I think
they just the the federal government can
just go to the court say we need this
information and you're saying the
corporations will hand it over yeah
right right Verizon all these big big
companies I think they've been know I
think there's been reports that they
just do the only company that I that I'm
aware of that gave them the government
the middle finger was Apple when they
wanted to get into that guy's iPhone
because he committed a terrorist attack
and they wanted to open and then I think
the FED said you know what never mind we
don't need it we got it anyway I
apparent I mean that that might have
been how it was resolved I don't
remember but I do remember that Apple
was like no we're not we're not because
they wanted to build a back door or
something like that and they're like
look if we if we show you a back door or
build a back door into this that it it's
for all of them then yeah and actually
in terms of what Apple's trying to build
the best marketing for the fact that
they have it is that they publicly say
no to the FBI and then they're like n
we're not giving it to you because we
built a thing and that's good for
everyone else too so byy our products
I'm thinking like if I keep thinking
decentralized social media so that the
companies don't have access to your
messages they're all encrypted
peer-to-peer but now I'm like well if
those truly are weapons of war social
media machines and things that social
media algorithms we can't decent or
could we decentralize Boeing that
wouldn't make a lot of sense because
then it becomes a security risk how do
you build a plane when the parts aren't
in the same building you'd have to get
them to ship them to their location and
if one of those factories goes down and
can't get the bolts over to the main
Factory to put the aircraft together the
entire thing shuts down so it's almost
like a risk not to have it centralized
that's that's that's how stuff goes as
it is especially like in actually we
talked about this the other night the
military um if you're building a complex
piece of equipment for the military they
try to spr spread out the actual parts
manufacturing into as many congressional
districts as possible so that way if you
want to get rid of a a program you're
getting rid of a bunch of jobs that
Congress people are like ah you're not
taking these jobs from my district yeah
I was talking to Congressman Gates about
that and he was telling me that uh some
of the some of the smartest folks that's
how they'll do it with some of these
fighter jets and whatnot they'll make
sure that you know a piece is made in
every single state that way you know
you'll have every all the representation
fighting to keep that same fighter
um online and it's smart you know but it
I don't know man it's definitely not
it's definitely not in the best interest
of the American people right it's an
addiction yeah it's it's it's a
programmed addiction by these uh uh
government actors making these deals
whoever it may be legislators or
otherwise where they're they're trying
to make sure we can never shut down a
government program that's the biggest
problem we have with government is the
inability for it to fail so when bad
things happen when corrupt things happen
and when failure happens the machine
keeps going sucking in more and more
money becoming more and more corrupt and
then eventually imploding thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net